[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 25 février
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition du 7 8
journal la jeunesse souhaite également
faire entendre sa voix dans le grand
débat national vendredi près de 80
collégiens et lycéens ont participé à
une réunion qui leur était dédiée à
poissy initiative de la députée du
secteur en présence du ministre de
l'éducation nationale
cette phase de concertation doit
s'achever le 15 mars prochain combien de
réunions ont été organisées sur le
territoire
comment prendre part encore aux
discussions à moins de trois semaines de
la fin de ce grand débat nous faisons le
plein dans le département et puis
l'entreprise verra le jour le 12 mars à
saint quentin en yvelines elle n'est pas
comme les autres cette société sera
éphémère un dispositif pour permettre
aux participants de revenir à l'emploi
nous en parlons avec sandrine jean est
chef de projet de l'entreprise éphémère
mais avant de développer ces titres ce
matin une fuite d'hydrocarbures a été
décelée sur le 'pipeline' total au
niveau 2 des communes d'eau tout y est
et de boissy sans avoir la situation à
13 heures 15 entre 4 et 7 hectares de
champs tout chez elle mais aussi des
rivières indique la préfecture des
yvelines
total a activé sa cellule de crise et
son plan de surveillance
vingt pompiers de la cellule
antipollution se sont rendus sur place
et un poste de commandement a été ouvert
au centre de secours de méré 137
habitants évacués vendredi de la rue au
pain dans le centre ville de saint
germain en laye dans la journée un
expert avait décelé un péril imminent
d'effondrement pour l'immeuble du numéro
20 20 bâtiments justement avaient été
évacuées préventivement et un périmètre
de sécurité établi est dès ce week-end
les résidents ont pu regagner leur
domicile sauf ceux habitant au numéro
vingt sept appartements sont encore
concernées de commerce restent également
fermée est la ville qui a débloqué en
urgence un budget pour des travaux de
consolidation de l'immeuble qui ont
commencé ce matin le point sur la
situation avec marylise marillys macé
est maire adjointe en charge de
l'urbanisme
les charpentiers de paris à qui sont des
experts dans ce genre de travaux sont à
pied d'oeuvre depuis ce matin donc il va
y avoir des travaux de compte
l'ida sion sur la façade d'un immeuble
et puis le sous sol d'un autre la rue
est bien évidemment fermée à la
circulation pour l'instant circulation
automobile et puis nous prévoyons deux
semaines de chantier il ya une deuxième
étape qui a commencé ce matin puisque on
a ouvert ce matin une procédure
ce qu'on appelle un référé pour repérer
les lignes c'est une démarche
administrative qui va déclencher le
passage d'un expert et cet expert va
rendre un rapport définitif
hélas la ville sera exactement ce
qu'elle doit faire et c'est seulement
après la vie de cet expert que pourrait
être décidé la réouverture des
habitations concernées elles la
municipalité en tout cas ouvert un point
d'accueil au centre administratif pour
recueillir est les informations et
observations des habitants concernant
l'état des immeubles du centre ville
le grand débat national se poursuit
c'est une réunion spécialement dédié à
la jeunesse qui était organisée vendredi
à poissy un rendez vous initié par
florence grange du député de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines et pour ce
grand débat des jeunes le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a fait le déplacement les
précisions de michael et demi d'euros et
de manon varaldo au théâtre blanche de
castille de poissy collégiens et lycéens
partagent leurs idées avec la députée et
florence grand jus pour ce grand débat
national spécial jeunes mais aussi avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer présents pour
l'occasion
là la surprise qu'on a eue d'avoir le
ministre de l'éducation c'était vraiment
exceptionnel parce que du coup c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu dévié des grands
thèmes du grand débat national
dans ce grand débat il n'est pas
question d'écologie de fiscalité ou de
pouvoir d'achat pour les 15 20 ans
d'autres questions s'imposent stage à
l'étranger téléphones portables dans les
établissements ou encore cours
d'enseignement moral et civique
ce hasard souvent de
pavages de grandes histoires volent aux
posters honnêtement donc voilà c'est
dommage parce que nous on est le col et
ceux qui vont être la nouvelle
génération qui va faire la suite de
notre pays
des jeunes qui se sentent souvent
exclues du grand débat et qui peine à y
participer à la fin de ces deux heures
des échanges d idées ont pu émerger
certaines ont particulièrement retenu
l'attention de jean michel blanck hier
c'est un moment très agréable parce
qu'on voit les jeunes qui ont envie de
s'engager qui ont aussi beaucoup de
questions à poser
par exemple y en a un qui a proposé une
banque de stages etc donc on sent aussi
des tonalités on sent des attentes de la
jeunesse sur certains sujets c'est
important de pouvoir grâce aux grands
débats de bien capter ses idées on a
tout l'avenir devant soi quand on a 15
16 ans et il faut pas s'arrêter au fait
qu'on vive dans un quartier politique de
la ville où le fait qu' on n'est pas
toujours les résultats scolaires adéquat
pour rentrer dans telle ou telle filière
et les jeunes nous ont montré qu'ils
étaient en capacité d'y croire et c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a le plus marqué le
grand débat national se clôturera le 15
mars
le grand débat lancé pour rappel le 15
janvier dernier en réponse à la crise
dès gilet jaune et qui devrait s'achever
avec des mesures concrètes
à trois semaines de la fin de cette
consultation quelle mobilisation dans
les yvelines ont fait le point avec
aurélie aux premières étapes de cette
consultation les cahiers de doléances
jusqu'au 20 février les yvelinoises et
les yvelinois ont pu se rendre dans
leurs mairies et inscrire leurs idées
dans ses registres
que vont devenir les cahiers de
doléances
les maires des communes devait les
transmettre à la préfecture des yvelines
avant le 22 février
environ 120 cahier d'expression
citoyenne ont été centralisés dans notre
département
la bibliothèque nationale de france est
ensuite chargé de les référencer et de
numériser leurs contenus combien de
réunions d'initiatives locales ont été
organisées
mené par des citoyens attrape ou par des
élus à poissy ces réunions se sont
déroulées aux quatre coins du
département depuis le 15 janvier
les participants se sont penchés sur les
thématiques proposées par le
gouvernement à savoir la transition
écologique la fiscalité la démocratie
citoyenne ou encore l'organisation de
l'état selon les chiffres de la
préfecture au 21 février dans les
yvelines 167 réunion d'initiatives
locales ont été programmés ou réaliser
peut-on encore participer jusqu'au 15
mars vous avez trois possibilités
assister aux réunions d'initiative
locale contribuer sur la plateforme en
ligne ou bien transmettre votre
contribution par voie postale à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran
enfin le département des yvelines
accueillera les 26 et 27 février
descente de proximité itinérant lagarde
devait participer animé par des
étudiants
ils ont pour objectif de recueillir la
parole citoyenne de personnes qui
n'auraient pas encore contribué au débat
et puis une nouvelle entreprise
implantée sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines elle sera basée à
partir du 12 mars à montigny le
bretonneux face au mieux mais d' une
société d'une durée de vie de cette
semaine seulement bonsoir sandrine jean
est immense
vous êtes la chef de projet de cette
entreprise éphémère qui va accompagner
50 personnes dans leur retour dans un
retour vers l'emploi alors expliquez
nous déjà le concept c'est quoi cette
entreprise est fumeur alors le but de
cette entreprise éphémère c'est de
collecter le maximum d'offres d'emploi
est ce cette collecte se fait sur la
base 50 personnes volontaires qui sont
en recherche d'emploi plutôt des
personnes d'ailleurs en recherche
d'emploi de longue durée qui vont donc
se fédérer ce que ce s'organisait tous
ensemble
et fonctionner pendant cette semaine
comme une vraie entreprise c'est la
d'innovation fin le concept innovant par
rapport à d'autres dispositifs plus
classique de retour vers l'emploi
exactement parce qu'ils sont en
situation on va dire de travail et donc
ils vont on va s'organiser en différents
services on va avoir un service
commercial qui va faire de la
prospection de face à face un call
center qui va faire de la prospection
par téléphone en service rh qui va faire
le lien entre les offres qui arrivent et
bien sûr des compétences et les talents
qu'on a dans l'entreprise éphémère
et puis un service communication qui va
aussi prendre contact avec tous les
médias pour faire parler du projet et
attirer l'intérêt des chefs d'entreprise
que ces chefs d'entreprise ouvrent leurs
portes à nos associés de l'entreprise
éphémère pour les aider à retrouver un
poste fonctionne et on l'a bien compris
comme une entreprise classique alors ce
sont 50 à sociaux on parle bien
d'associer pendant cette période plus de
demandeurs d'emploi exactement on leur
demande de quitter l'arabie de
demandeurs d'emploi de devenir associé
pourquoi en fait le terme d' associer
pourquoi l'idée bien sûr c'est tout ça
et en virtuel leur statut ne change pas
on leur demande d'être on leur propose
en fait d'être associé parce qu'on veut
qu'ils se placent d'égal à égal
finalement avec le chef chef
d'entreprise qui vont aller démarcher
pour aussi ils ne sont pas là pour
vendre par les quémander par les
chercher un emploi
ils sont là surtout pour proposer un
service qui est celui de service de
recrutement pour l'entreprise donc ça va
durer sept semaines vous en avez parlé
vont faire du sourcing d'emploi c'est ça
pendant ces 7 5 d'offres d'emploi du
marché caché essentiellement c'est à
dire le marché qui n'est pas visible sur
les réseaux sociaux qui n'est pas
visible sur internet tout ce qui en fait
et dans les réseaux mais qui ne jamais
publier et quel bénéfice pour pour ses
cinquante personnes de participer à ce
genre d'initiative s'est plaint de
bénéfices le premier c'est d'abord le
retour à l'emploi puisque un tiers des
personnes à l'issue de nos pros de notre
programme
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a pu observer
dans les expérimentations précédentes
puisque saint quentin sur la 9e
entreprises éphémère donc un tiers des
personnes retrouvent en poste à l'issue
du programme donc à l'issue dès cette
semaine et deux tiers dans les 6 mois
donc déjà un retour à l'emploi
alors pour une majorité d'entre eux pour
la personne individuellement reprise de
confiance redynamisation dans sa
recherche d'emploi
ensuite des compétences plus renforcée
je dirais sur le plan de la prospection
elles sont les personnes sont bonnes
nous disait beaucoup plus à l'aise
dedans quand il s'agit de contacter un
employeur mais aussi elle se prend elle
sont beaucoup plus professionnel dans
leur recherche d'emploi
et puis sur le plan digital il ya aussi
une évolution une amélioration de leurs
compétences parce que il ya une
plateforme digitale qui accompagne le
projet et c'est vrai que l'utiliser
pendant cette semaine ça les fait monter
en compétences sur ce faire le plan dans
ce dispositif a fait ses preuves
notamment à grenoble valence ou encore à
bagneux en région parisienne pour y
participer les candidatures sont à
déposer jusqu'au 8 mars
à qui s'adresse ce dispositif vous les
10 des demandeurs d'emploi de longue
durée ce que tu as perdu confiance dans
la recherche d'emploi donc on est
demandeur plus d'emplois de plus tôt de
plus d'un an on va dire dans les plus
d'un an mais que prioritairement issus
des quartiers prioritaires pas forcément
prioritairement non mais oui une
attention particulière est portée à ces
personnes qui se trouvent dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville bien sûr on les accueillera
avec grand plaisir on a encore des
places aujourd'hui on a déjà pas mal de
candidature donc il est important de
réagir vite
il faut être disponible quatre jours par
semaine donc du lundi au jeudi
ensuite sauf la première semaine ça sera
du lundi au vendredi la première semaine
être motivé
avoir vraiment être en recherche active
d'emploi voilà les et savoir naviguer
sur internet et pour candidater on
dépose sur le site arrêt sur le site
internet entreprises www.entrepose.fr et
du milieu éphémère au plurielles.fr mais
qui s'affiche actuellement bas de
l'écran quels sont les objectifs pour
cette première entreprise éphémère sur
le territoire de saint quentin
les objectifs se serait de bien sûr
d'être 50 déjà essayé un bel objectif
et puis d'atteindre au moins les
résultats qu'on a pu observer sur
d'autres sont deux autres
expérimentations et si si ça marche
pourquoi pas une deuxième entreprise
éphémère merci sandrine jean est chef de
projet de cette entreprise éphémère je
rappelle la date limite du dépôt des
candidatures c'est le 8 mars et des
sessions d'information sont organisées à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines la prochaine c'est demain mardi
de 9h30 à et à 9h30 et 11h30 de cession
est également le 4 mars à 14h et 15h30
et bien sûr toutes les informations sur
le site internet entreprises éphémère
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
et pour un tour complet de l'actualité
sportive rendez vous dans quelques
minutes avec l'émission 7,8 sport
présentée par michael et demi d'euros
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]